Trade Commissioner service for for seven
years but I do remember it very fondly
and I probably know some of the people
in your group but maybe not most of them
right yeah well some of the old
stalwarts are still there Jim Elliot
right you might know some of them all
right I wonder if you get a list of who
is attending this session er sorry to
interrupt but we're live on YouTube to
begin this so here I am those of you who
follow me on my youtube channel you know
me I'm Steve the Keene language learner
and an early part of my career I was
just I was in the Canadian Trade
Commissioner service which is part of
the diplomatic service that part of the
diplomatic service that deals with trade
and helping Canadians sell their
products overseas negotiating you know
access for Canadian products and all
this kind of thing and so because of
that I regularly get copied on an email
sent out by John Lang for those former
members of the Diplomatic Service who
live around Ottawa and they gathered
together in a pub and drink beer there
and so because of kovat john suggested
that since they can't get together that
it would be a good idea to have
different former trade commissioners or
foreign service officers talk about some
things that might be of interest to
other members of the group so I
volunteered that I would talk about my
experience with learning languages after
the age of 60 so that's what's behind
this and we'll have a group of you know
20 or so people and I look forward to
talking to them and John Lang is the
organizer I joined okay welcome Steve
okay so yeah I would say that my initial
exposure to language learning was when I
was a trade commissioner because
although I had spent three years as a
student in France and therefore yeah I
got my French opt a pretty good level
because I have to do
my classes in French you know I went to
see osto in Paris
not long after Pierre Trudeau but you
know I don't want to accept any you know
blame for that but I was sent to Hong
Kong as a Chinese language you know
student because Canada was getting ready
to recognize the People's Republic of
China and they needed people who could
speak English I speak Chinese and so I
was sent there so I learned Chinese and
that went in and out of China was at the
Kapton trade fair quite a few times went
up to Beijing with our first Canadian
mission there to find a site for our
embassy as we in fact did recognize
China and I was with you know a small
group of people and that was my first
TAS in Beijing was amazing to see
Beijing in 1970 and Beijing in 1970 is
not at all like the Beijing of today
Beijing in 1970 was much much closer to
Beijing in 1870 than Beijing of today is
the Beijing of 1970 not much has changed
then I was in Japan for nine years and
you know I was in the sort of
international trade in wood products and
I you know obviously my Japanese
language that I picked up while living
in Japan was very beneficial because I
was offered a position with first one
then another major BC lumber exporting
company based on the fact that I could
speak Japanese and had very good
contacts in the downstream sort of wood
distribution and homebuilders sector in
Japan and then I set up my own company
and we did a lot of business in Europe
and so German and Swedish even to some
extent Spanish and so along the way I
developed I would say starting with my
Chinese experience a certain sort of
approach to learning languages an
approach that basically you know what I
sort of discovered was mostly you just
have to get the language in you if you
try to approach the language via theory
via grammatical explanation via
declension tables you will be defeated
because it's in
possible to remember those things if
your brain has not been exposed to
enough of the language once you have a
sense of the language through massive
exposure listening and reading then some
of these explanations start to make
sense because they refer to something
that you already know but if you try to
explain the language before you've had
this exposure you don't understand the
explanation you certainly won't remember
it you won't be able to apply it when
you speak because you need to develop
certain habits now in your exposure to
the language you may not notice certain
things so it is possible that a grammar
explanation might point out some small
details that you missed but
overwhelmingly for the bulk of the
language that you have to get into you
as a habit as a new language habit that
comes that comes from massive listening
and reading and so I mean probably I
don't know if you can see it but in
behind me is a massive amount of CDs in
every possible language from Russian to
German to Japanese - Spanish - check -
Swedish and so for a long time I used to
listen to these CDs and read the
corresponding book or eventually ebook
prior to that when I was learning
Chinese of course we have these open
real tape recorders so I had to sit in
my room and listen to the tape recorder
but I listened a lot and that in Hong
Kong I would go to bookstores scouring
the bookstores for readers in Chinese
were there were you know sort of
wordless beside each lesson because to
look something up in a dictionary
particularly in Chinese where it's so
time-consuming to look something up in a
dictionary and then when we closed the
dictionary we have already forgotten
whatever the meaning was that was there
I mean that's just how it is language
learning is about forgetting so you have
to have some means of having these the
meaning of these words words that you
didn't know you buck them up you kind of
start to know you still don't know it it
has to be handy for you and what has
happened to language learning
I would say in the last 10-15 years is
that we no longer have open real tape
recorders we don't even really need CDs
anymore because we can download
everything we need from the internet
because we and we can listen to it on
our iPhone we can listen to it on our
computer if you want we can listen to it
on our iPod Nano when we go jogging in
other words the audio has become so
tremendously
you know portable the other thing that
has happened is that if we read in an
electronic format we can click on words
and immediately see the meaning we can
forget them again but at least it's easy
to see quickly you know what the meaning
was and then you continue reading in the
text so you stay in the text you don't
get sidetracked by it spending 30
seconds to look something up in the
dictionary so what has happened so with
these things happening at the age of 60
I decided to learn Russian oh by the way
around that time yeah so I decided to
learn Russian and we decided my son and
I decided to create a website for
language learning the background of that
is that I had a company in wood product
and we were buying wood from Europe from
North America we were shipping to Japan
we were shipping to Europe we were
dealing with currencies of nominal net
metric board feet and and of course
shipping schedules and customers wanted
to know when the wood was coming and we
wanted to make sure that the mills were
producing on time so we had a department
that created this software software that
enabled us to enabled us to manage all
of this information you know Paul our
schedules produce shipping documents and
so forth so we had this software
capability I was learning Cantonese I
found out about a Chinese immigrant to
Canada who had all have you know his
savings stolen at Vancouver Airport and
I was listening to Cantonese radio local
radio here and heard about him and I
said well we'll hire this guy because he
was in IT and if he's good and that's
good for us and if he's no good then at
least we helped him out he stayed six
months there
to China but he had a high-scoring TOEFL
test of English as a foreign language
but he couldn't communicate really in
English he didn't really understand what
we were saying we had a lot of trouble
understanding what he was saying so we
developed a system we developed a system
whereby people who are already at a sort
of low intermediate level by listening
to content that's relevant to them and
having the ability to look up words and
save words to a database and review
these words that we developed a bunch of
functionality that would help these
people like this immigrants specifically
initially improve his English well he
events he went back to China we then had
this system we went to the government to
say look you have a lot of skilled
immigrants coming to Canada and I knew
from my own experience that a lot of
these so-called skilled immigrants
particularly from China where the
language skills are not great they ended
up working in a warehouse somewhere for
$5 an hour for another Chinese you know
boss and I felt that those people could
improve their language skills in fact I
knew that the biggest obstacle those
people faced was their language it
wasn't at a level where they could
operate in a office environment
unfortunately the Immigration Department
is more interested in sort of supporting
what they consider to be the
stakeholders and that is the Immigration
Service Organizations
they in turn are only interested in
getting bodies into their classroom so
they can get more funding from the
government we never got anywhere with
that and then we decided well we'll make
it a multi-language platform where
people around the world teach each other
their languages and so now we have 37
languages a good portion of the language
content that we have for each language
is provided by our members and each
lesson in any language consists of audio
with text so with the audio you can
download if it's a course of 10 lessons
you can download them to your iPhone
listen to it whenever you want as a
playlist you can add individual lessons
to a playlist so you can listen to it
whenever wherever you want which is what
I do I listen when I'm making breakfast
because I I'm gonna get
something makes breakfast I listen when
I'm cleaning up after having a wonderful
gourmet meal prepared by my wife it's
only fair that I clean up but I listen
so and I mean if I'm in the car I listen
if I'm exercising I listen so there's
lots of opportunity to listen so when
you listen then you don't understand you
may understand 10 20 30 40 50 percent so
then I mean you know I'm curious now I
want them I want to know what that was
so then I go to our lesson page in our
system link and then I can look up words
every time if I see a word that the
system tells me if it's a word I haven't
seen before I then look it up and then
changes color as I get to know the word
better it changes color again it creates
flashcards it creates statistics I have
a sense of how many words I've read how
many words I know and on and on I mean
there's a lot of functionality there oh
I was gonna say by the way that when I
started on this I wrote a book about
language learning which was also
translated into Chinese I even went to
China and gave talks about it and what
was written in 19 I don't know 2003
maybe and basically nothing that I wrote
there about how languages are learned
has changed I remain convinced that
contrary to a to the way languages are
taught where there's a lot of emphasis
on getting people to say things and
getting people to say things correctly
and which of course is impossible
because and which only leads to
frustration the emphasis should be
entirely on comprehension a much more
sort of passive approach building up our
vocabulary building up our sense of the
language building up sort of a comfort
zone so that when we start to speak we
have a greater chance of achieving
success and at that point when we review
issues of grammar we have a better
chance of understanding those issues of
grammar and and applying them so that
will be my introductory diatribe and I
look forward to questions Steve I think
you're absolutely right I can remember
that a few times that I studied
languages prior to going on a post
being frustrated at being introduced to
the Future pluperfect conjunctive before
I actually knew how to find out asked to
ask where is the train station right it
was they were following a curriculum
which for absolutely no resemblance to
my requirements yeah this is true and
and they continue to do it they continue
to do it okay let me see if I see a
question
John's 11 I'm in violent agreement with
steve-o John 11 wants to speak so Eric
can you enable John for eleven you see
that are you still with us Eric yes I
will give John accessing okay sure all
right
I like the violent agreement that's much
better than violent disagreement all
right oh here we are but you're muted
don't up okay I'm in complete agreement
first posting Sao Paulo
having done French in Canada and all
that stuff and Beverly and I went to a
language school outside of Rio five days
a week five hours a day entirely in
Portuguese with the teacher who spoke no
English or French and what we did each
night for about another five hours was
memorized dialogue and I later learned
that this was actually the Berlitz
approach why it never was the Canadian
government's French language school
approach or indeed the Ontario secondary
school French teachers approach I have
never understood because the secret is
just as you say this is of course before
[Music]
electronic means the secret was to get
you talking the way a child learns a
language don't worry about mistakes and
the truth is that in in in four weeks
four or five weeks I could speak
Portuguese well enough that I usually
didn't need a translator except the time
I agreed to a tailor and saw Paulo
putting buttons on my side pockets on my
suit but absolutely right and I I just
think somehow the language establishment
in Ottawa they're not in the well this
is ancient times no they really weren't
in the communications business right
they were in the profession business but
it approaches entire
correct thanks Steve I saw in the Q&A
Eric that Bob Fairweather would like to
speak but it's disappeared now and so
answered or sure one moment speak okay
all right so I'm assuming then that Eric
is on top of all the questions and
comments and he can enable people to
speak John I would say that obviously if
you have the luxury of having a teacher
five hours a day then that is ideal but
for many people learning languages
that's just not possible so I have found
and I have to admit that when I was
learning Mandarin Chinese I had three
hours a day with a teacher but now I
don't have that option and I don't
really want to be three hours a day on
skype with tutors so I have found that
the portability of just listening
listening and reading eventually I start
to speak and in my most recent languages
Farsi Arabic and Turkish I went at it
for three months with lots of listening
and started doing it once or twice a
week with a tutor and at the end of that
I was speaking but the bulk of the time
that I spent was the time that's so easy
to organize and that's just plain
listening reading again if you live in
Brazil if I lived when I lived in Japan
it was easier to get out and just use
what you have
not so easy say here in Vancouver I
occasionally sneak up on local Iranian
and hit them with my Persian with great
delight on their part anyway I see Rob
do not care whether he's ready to go
here let's beep yeah I hear you
oh good first of all I like to say hello
to everyone who's on the web cam system
it's this room is great and it's nice to
see some old faces a couple of things
would you stop referring to your son
Marcus Eric yeah that's not no no that's
not Marc sorry Bob modern technology
because of our account with zoom but
exactly Eric Robertson who works for
link o who is managing the controls
Ericka's in London whatever they're
doing over there and Mark is busy
working Oh
in fact it is Eric but not my son Eric
but Eric Roberts a concern that Steve's
gone center aisle I appreciate Mark's
names on the board you prefer and Eric
whom I know is your your eldest son but
I just know I just want to make a
comment about Steve's language ability
I've been with him on a number of
occasions when we run into people at a
sushi restaurant and speaking Japanese
or for the sushi restaurant speaking
Chinese and with great facility moves
between Cantonese and Mandarin and
amazes the people so his approach to
language learning has a lot of
credibility as far as I'm concerned
because I know that within a short
period of time with his dedication to
learning any specific language he comes
out speaking it very well and so good on
you Steve and I don't know I think
you're up to what 20 languages now or
something I'm working on 19 and 20
alloys listening to Turkish this morning
which would be 21 but I can't say that I
speak them well but I do enjoy them I do
enjoy them I listen to I listen to
podcasts from Al Jazeera a podcast on al
Jazeera and it's very topical they're
talking about John Bolton's book and
trumped and the cat her you know
blockading being blockaded but it's
interesting so you learn the language
and through the language you learn a
bunch of stuff it's nice to know that
someone of our age and still learn a
language so you go hordes here but you
know one thing that I find very
frustrating with Bob is that you know
and and like I find that the more time I
put into learning languages the better I
get that's not true with golf and it
pisses me off when I go out and play
golf with Bob because he's just so much
better than I am
and I do John
wish that I were closer to Ottawa to
attend some of the pub meetings but I'm
glad that I'm on your circulation list
so at least I know when they are and if
ever I'm in Ottawa that they could find
a time to you can have a vicarious
bigger with us I see a question here
from Alf Davis what do you think the
babble approach um you know what I'm not
sure that I know what the babble
approach is I am familiar with rosetta
stone duolingo I don't know you know
obviously if you ask me what I think of
any other approach I'm gonna say it's no
good
I am prejudiced all right but I do
happen to believe that any approach that
uses pictures or multiple-choice or
things of that nature that is not how at
least how I like to learn languages I
think you want to start with some kind
of context so in my own case when I
start a language link we have these 60
mini stories each of the many stories
has a lot of repetition they're focused
on the high frequency verbs needwant
give take go come all this kind of stuff
and they exist in are in over 30
languages and there's so much repetition
in each story and I listen to these over
and over and over again and that's how I
get launched into a language no pictures
because you know how are you gonna
represent need or want or give or take
it's just difficult you can't use
pictures for everything duolingo has a
lot of disjointed sentences and phrases
of these sort of give you whereas the
stories as it's not they're not
necessarily tremendously interesting
because they've been written using these
high-frequency verbs and high frequency
column conjunctions but as you listen to
it and listening is such an easy thing
to do I don't have to sit in front of
the screen and look at
teachers I can be in my car I can be
working out so you know that's what I
tend to do and our functionality at Lync
is built around that concept but of
course there are other systems rosetta
stone Babel whatever and and I I think I
would be jaundiced against them if I
were to comment on Pimsleur or whatever
so short of knowing more about Babel is
not much I can say to out this all right
any other questions Q and a what do we
got here in Q&A okay how does one begin
when the language is idea graphic or
Cyrillic
okay well Cyrillic is a lot easier than
idea graphic okay Cyrillic I mean in my
own case I read some languages that have
alphabets and Cyrillic obviously is an
alphabet so for Russian for Ukrainian
then Greek I can read and Hangul which
is the Korea and all of those you have a
finite now and even Arabic which is
Arabic Persian which is kind of more
difficult because it's not always
obvious how things are pronounced but at
least there's a finite number of symbols
whereas once you get into Chinese and
Japanese there's just a lot of work in
learning those characters so in the case
of Chinese characters I had a system
back fifty years ago I had 1,000
flashcards actual real flashcards not
the computer variety and I would take
ten of them every day and I would write
the first one out ten times and I had
this sort of squared paper so I'd write
the first idea gram or character out ten
times down one column then I would put
the meaning three columns over pick
another one write it down and by the
third character I've run into the first
one again because I put it over three
columns to the right and then I write it
again ten times so I would do this for
ten characters I eventually got it up to
thirty characters
basic assumption is that half of what
you learn you're gonna forget so you
have to shuffle the cards back into the
pile and learn them again and again and
again
but like so much in language learning if
you stay with it you will gradually get
better the brain learns the brain learns
slowly but the brain learns so I think
this is an important point and with
regard to Cyrillic I mean you just have
to stay with it or Arabic at first it's
very difficult it's never quite as
comfortable as reading in the Latin
alphabet but slowly you get better like
in everything to do with language we
slowly get better if we keep doing it
and I think sometimes the people who are
not so successful in language learning
they become impatient they feel they
should be able to speak correctly now
they should be able to understand
everything now and of course it doesn't
work that way and even some of the most
basic things like the word for not an
old shoe or something when we need it we
can't find even though we in fact know
that word so I mean there's so many
things opportunities for people to get
frustrated in language learning but if
you if you accept the fact that the
brain is there to create like patterns
that's what the brain does that's how we
get through life because a brain half
the time anticipate what's gonna happen
because it's happened before and so the
brain that's what the brain does and we
have to trust the brain that they it
will gradually create patterns around
this new language and so whether it is a
matter of grammatical structures or
writing systems you just have to keep
going and I think a lot of people don't
have the patience you know or they want
to like Bob they want to go take all for
something so right okay do you have a
website to contact you Martha Davis so
yeah so you can contact me first of all
email first of all the name of the
website is that we use that I use this
wishes where I've learned since the age
of sixty I've learned more or less
eleven languages the site is called Linc
Li ng Q dark
car and if you want to send me an email
I'm Steve at Li ng q comm so and if you
want to watch my videos in different
languages you can go to my YouTube
channel which is called lingo Steve Li
and I see that is ready so that lingo
Steve is a is a YouTube channel where I
have in fact 250,000 subscribers I don't
think they'll show up every time but and
I talk and and my message is to
encourage people regardless of your age
regardless of any other consideration if
you want to learn the language and
you're willing to put in the time if you
have the right attitude you're going to
you're going to learn and yeah so you
can have a look there too okay any other
questions okay
oh yeah question in the Q&A here Oh Bob
for there no oh oh Peter travel don't
you mix languages when you speak so many
yes absolutely and obviously you know
you have to make a choice like I could
try to focus on one language and become
as good at that language as it's
possible to be or I can continue
exploring new languages once you start
exploring new languages obviously you're
not going to be as good in the earlier
languages as you would like to be and
you are also going to start confusing
and but to me my main objective in
learning a language is is comprehension
and exploring that language like right
now by being able to understand some
Arabic some Persian some Turkish I have
a totally different perspective on the
Middle East
it drives me to read books I'm reading a
book right now about the Persian
influence in India for example I have a
better understanding of how those
cultures have interacted with each other
and and the other thing I like to do is
I like to be able to communicate so I
can communicate with mistakes I can
speak Portuguese and of course my
Portuguese is not as good as my Spanish
and so it's sometimes called Fortuno
because I throw Spanish into my
Portuguese but everyone understands me
and I understand them so and and of
course if I go let's say I was in Brazil
a year or so ago and I'm very much as I
moved from Argentina in the Brazil it
was heavier to port than y'all and by
the third day was closer to Portuguese
so I think one of the conditions of
being a successful language learner is
that you have to accept imperfection
uncertainty not understanding not
remembering getting things wrong I mean
that just goes with the territory
if you don't like those things then you
stay in your own language
the other thing I do if I know like a
tomorrow morning I have a
live stream in Russia so I haven't been
doing any Russian and Russian is one of
those languages that has a lot of
grammatical issues you know verbs of
motion declension whatnot so I will
spend a few hours listening to stuff on
our website particularly our many
stories to try to at least refresh some
of those habits so you can just simply
by listening and reading you can refresh
some habits bring back some vocabulary
so then when you start speaking you
might make fewer mistakes but you'll
still make mistakes and personally it
doesn't bother me as long as I can
understand what they're saying and I can
get my meaning across with the odd you
know mistake that's fine with me
are there and so Jenna - are there any
languages that do not have a rhythm and
are therefore harder to learn um okay I
mean obviously every language has its
rhythm French is more monotonous than
English Chinese like Mandarin there the
intonation actually affects the meaning
of the individual words in English we
have similar you know high rising high
falling similar tones to Chinese but we
use them for emphasis French is more
monotonous but still there is that
rhythm in French and I think it's very
important to try to capture that rhythm
when we're imitating the language and
for example when I learn a language at
link we have a thing called sentence
mode where I can go into and go through
a lesson sentence by sentence and many
of our lessons are time-stamped so that
I can have not text to speech but
actually the original voice saying that
sentence and then I'll try and repeat
you know the sentence the way the native
speaker said it to try to get that
natural intonation because I think a big
part of pronunciation is actually
getting the rhythm the intonation of the
language and very often English speakers
you know when they speak French for
example and they throw English
intonation in there we get the standard
English version of French and the goal I
think it's if you're speaking French to
try to be a little more you know to
capture the intonation of French I'm not
aware of any language that has no
intonation I think their intonation
for each language is different Swedish
is very up and down Spanish especially
in Spain is much more machine gun and
those are just things that we try to
imitate
okay
huh genetic component alright so yes my
parents I'm not sure it's genetic
genetic component is to suggest that for
example in Sweden a lot of people speak
English very well or in Holland or in
Singapore and therefore those people
have some language gene I don't believe
it's genetic I believe that that as a
child I was exposed to a number of
languages because I was born in Sweden
moved to Canada when I was five my
parents were originally from
Czechoslovakia they spoke German and
Chuck at home so I heard these languages
even though I couldn't speak however
there are polyglot gatherings around the
world polyglot conferences and I
sometimes attendees and I give talks
there and I was in a room of 600 people
in Montreal and what is known as the
long Festa Festival day long polyglot
conference 600 people I said you know in
my own case I had this language exposure
as a child although I promptly forgot
Swedish so essentially by the age of 16
I was unilingual English because I had I
was a victim of the French language
instruction in English language schools
in Canada but I said in this room how
many of you grew up in a family that was
bulky lingual and these are all
polyglots and if you ever go to one of
these polyglot gatherings people have
you know tags on where they have a flag
of every language they speak and they'll
have ten flags and so if you see a flag
of a language that you speak you can
then start talking to them in that
language so it's quite an exciting sort
of gathering of 600 people I don't think
there were five hands that that went up
so that the vast majority like the
overwhelming majority of those polyglots
in fact grew up in a monolingual family
and so it's possible that genetics
influences a thing it possible that
being exposed to languages influences
you at an early age it's possible that
age influences you it's possible that
I'm not as good a language learner now
as I was 50 years ago I think those
things are minor
I think the
the biggest thing is your attitude in
other words am i interested am i
interested in learning the language am i
interested in the language do I like the
language am i motivated do I believe I
can do it
do I believe learning the language is
worthwhile because it takes time so
while I'm doing it am I happy that I'm
doing it or do I wish I were out playing
golf like Bob you know being in the
moment that attitude thing is important
and the amount of time you spend so
people say well Steve you're just good
at languages yeah but nobody like I am a
total outlier in terms of the amount of
time that I'm willing to spend on
languages you know who else gets up in
the morning every morning and starts
listening to Arabic while making
breakfast all right that puts me in a
special category I don't know what
category that is so the answer to your
question is I don't I don't think the
genetic consideration or even being
exposed to languages at an early age is
as important as a person's motivation
and the amount of time they put in and
even if there are differences that
doesn't mean the person who is you know
less favored by genetics or family
environment can't learn it may be that
person a learns faster than person B but
person B will also learn I find the
Internet
making my German hear news from other
another perspective I use an Internet
yeah absolutely
I mean we live in a golden age of
language learning there are so many
resources available podcasts radio
stations Netflix YouTube YouTube has
subtitles we have a browser extension on
our website where we can bring in any
video from YouTube in Russian Turkish
and Spanish Chinese and it becomes a
lesson so that I can then read the
dialogue and learn those words and
phrases we can do the same with Netflix
but unfortunately Netflix blocks us from
bringing in the video and the audio but
at least I can get the dialogue and work
on the words and phrases so I mean if I
compare the environment today with the
internet and mp3 players etc with when I
lived in in Hong Kong
learning Chinese I wasn't about to pick
up my open reel tape recorder and
carried her ghettoblaster
carried around Hong Kong probably
wouldn't have lasted very long anyway
okay any other questions all right
Oh Bob I have a golf date so I have to
sign off now okay so you can humiliate
me again it was great Steve I'm
wandering around when I go on my health
walks listening to the radio station I
began listening to in 1969 in Sao Paulo
which is jobbing Punk that's how I keep
up my Portugal thing because I got some
podcasts from a global oh and they're
very good I keep listening to the
coronavirus crisis unfurl itself in
Brazil because they had this national
talk show right and when bolsa never
fired his health minister it was it was
a thing but anyway it's just fun to be
able to and whoa and by the way just so
we're clear
fifty years ago one of the main sponsors
on jobbing palm was a company called
pillow max that promised to grow here
they're still a major sponsor clearly I
did not buy enough ah you didn't do it
right
see if that was a great great discussion
okay well thank you very much for
everyone coming out and yeah good luck
thank you very much Steve
it's wonderful occupied and yes enjoying
something you're very good at
so you're an inspiration you know any
two person MS ah boy it does you must it
joy again okay thank you very much
everyone enjoy yourselves
thank you Steve bye-bye thanks John